[Music]
all right hello steve
good how are you doing max okay we're
really nice attacks poster like that
ah thanks you got good eyes man thank
you for that uh
no i'm really excited to be joined by
right now and before i even get into
this interview with max everybody just a
heads up we are going to be talking
spoilers
for season four episodes one two three
so make sure you watch those first
before we get into this
so as you're saying thank you for the
compliment max how you doing today
good man thank you for your time oh no
problem so
can you clear up for us with episode
three here we got a lot of nick
action and i'm wondering
was it totally nick's idea to bring
hannah in to get june to spill the beans
hero was he not even actually involved
with that process
so repeat the question for me one more
time so was nick the one behind
having hannah come in to see june to get
june to actually spill the beans of
where
the handmaids were or is that oh um
i definitely don't think so no i don't i
don't think
that nick would ever be capable of being
so personally responsible for something
that malevolent
especially not something that would have
that kind of
impact on june no that's all sort of
antithetical to
his intentions i think okay good you
know that's that's a relief to hear
because we want
nick is like literally one of the
biggest fan favorites of this show
and that's good to hear that for people
and it's interesting because
nick being a huge fan favorite there was
such an outcry last season for more
nick's screen time and we're getting
that
this season were you aware of that
reaction to the fans are you kind of
tune out that noise
um a little bit but i think
also sort of slightly confounded by it
um because
you know he i thought he was pretty
present
in season three but i also felt like the
story very naturally wanted a different
kind of focus at that point
in the narrative do you know what i mean
we're telling yeah a big story here
that's gonna run for a minute
you know we're we're doing a fifth
season of the show i don't think it's
giving anything away
so we've got somewhere to go um
and i felt as a viewer and a fan of the
show myself
that like that in season three my
interest was in a different direction
and
um nick was you know away
at you know at war and um
paying his dues so uh yeah he's back in
a he's not he's back in a
a different way this season i think he's
affected by those experiences
sure and we see him a different man too
because now he's just commander nick
we're getting to know and
what complicates this character so much
is it seems like he's like back and
forth with
valuing where he is in gilead and
keeping himself safe but
also protecting june can you kind of
clear maybe where you have
nick's head currently in the season yeah
i mean look
i i play him so i might be biased and um
sure
i see him through you know probably rose
tinted lenses but
my my understanding of nick is that he
he he's always sort of trying to
utilize his position to june's benefit
i think he has a tremendous amount of
guilt about
his history and his past and wants to
compensate
for that and this is his path
towards some kind of redemption
[Music]
at the same time he can't he can't
sacrifice his position because then he
can no longer be useful
so it's just kind of balancing out he's
always trying to
to figure out and he doesn't always get
it right which is what's so fun to play
but i i believe his heart is in the
right place
i want to see more of that because it
seems like there's just such a mystery
to this character and it's exciting
character
and you kill it here and people love
that you're getting now the screen time
again it's really exciting
uh thanks man max thank you so much for
joining me today
and everyone obviously check out the
handmaid's tale on hulu
every wednesday a new episode drops and
i hope to talk to you in the future
sometime
thanks steve i appreciate the time